- [Woman] I've lied, stolen,
and taken advantage of
everything to get laid.
I'm a sex addict and it's ruining my life.
- [Woman] I'm a sex addict.
I fantasize about strangers
taking advantage of me
in random public places.
- [Man] Being a sex addict
and being in a relationship
is a hard combo on a day
she doesn't wanna have any.
- [Woman] I hate that I'm a sex addict.
I feel like I'll never
have a real relationship
because of it.
- [Woman] I wish guys would stop
considering my sex addiction a turn on.
- [Man] Being a sex addict is not easy.
Everyone's always judging.
I'm tired of being that creepy
guy no one wants to talk to.
- [Woman] I'm addicted to
sex, but I'm finding myself
needing more and more to have an orgasm.
- [Man] My sex addiction
has changed me as a person.
I can't control the urges
and find myself distracted
by every beautiful woman that I see.
I don't gawk,
but I can't help to admire
their beauty and body.
- [Woman] I'm a sex addict,
and I don't like being told no.
I'm okay until my boyfriend
doesn't want me any more,
but then I cry from rejection.
- [Man] I'm a sex
addict, and it's annoying
because it ruins my
relationship with girls,
even though I don't cheat.
- [Man] No one knows
that I'm addicted to porn
and I was diagnosed as a sex addict.
I pretty much hide porn anywhere I can.
I feel like I'm a prisoner in my own body.
- [Man] It's been a month without sex
and I'm literally shaking,
feeling withdrawals
and struggling to keep moving forward.
- [Man] I live in fear of commitment
because of my sex addiction.
I don't wanna hurt anyone.
- [Man] I masturbate too much.
Every day, multiple times a day,
sometimes in public or
in the bathroom at work.
I'm literally addicted
to sex in all forms.
- [Man] I am a diagnosed sex addict.
Most people feel like it's not a big deal,
or a real condition.
If only people could understand
the hell it causes in my life.